let me just begin by Thank You Roger
hertog as well for making this possible
I want to also thank David Rosner and
the center for the study of the history
and ethics of Public Health that's
co-sponsoring this series I thank you
again for that David I want to also
thank Steve Morris my partner with this
program this summer this is the second
year of the hurt on global strategy
initiative and I can't imagine trying to
take on a subject like pandemics and
public health without Steve Morris of my
side so thank you Steve Steve is going
to be handling more expertly than I
could the question and answer session at
the end of this at the end of this talk
I'll just say very quickly why we're
here what the / toggleable strategy
initiative is all about basically this
is a program a research program that
brings together future historians future
practitioners we bring them together
with the idea that they will make
history together we'd like them to we'd
like them to over the course of the
summer undertake independent and
collaborative research projects use new
information technology help us better
understand the history of public health
and pandemic threats so that we can
better manage the future and the idea
with taking on subjects like nuclear
proliferation and terrorism last summer
this summer will be pandemics in public
health next summer climate change and
international security is that we're
taking on what we think of is some of
the most important problems in world
politics but one thing that makes them
so problematic is that they are so
difficult to predict some would say
maybe even impossible to predict when it
comes to the next pandemic but I wanted
to share with you one prediction just to
point out just a few things about our
speaker tonight why I'm so happy to have
her here this is a prediction that goes
back to nineteen seventy-two and it was
issued by a man who should have known
Nobel laureate named MacFarlane Burnett
who concluded and I'm quoting again that
the most likely forecast about the
future of infectious disease is that it
will be very dull
now this is just one of a number of
forecasts from that period about how it
is it seemed that the whole spectrum
infectious disease was fading because of
disease eradication programs and a lot
of other things but i think that the
already amazing career of Peggy Hamburg
shows how very wrong he was and how
sadly in a way interesting been exciting
the history of the last thirty and forty
years who's been in this field more
interesting all the time alas so I want
to again say how happy I am that he's
here I want to welcome her back as well
to New York and even this neighborhood
where she lived for a time when she was
the youngest commissioner of health in
New York that was just one of a number
of things that he's done in this field
and even in the time that she was there
she managed to bring down the rate of
tuberculosis by almost fifty percent
taking on for instance some of those who
thought that it should not be a priority
at least not in New York City jails she
was somebody also who backed needle
exchange programs and that way combated
the spread of hiv/aids she brought up
childhood vaccination rates these are
just some of the things that you learn
about Peggy Hamburg when you just begin
to read about her there are a few things
so that you wouldn't learn at least not
right away things that I think we're
kind of fun the fact for instance that
she had to grow up with very eminent
parents and I can only imagine what a
challenge that must have been to have a
father who's the president of the New
York not in New York I'm sorry the
Institute of Medicine in the National
Academies her mother also had been
elected to membership and when she
became a member as I understand it this
is the only example of a mother and a
father and a daughter who all of them
were elected to membership in the
Institute of Medicine and her daughters
are not going to have it easy either
they as I understand it are the only
children who have on their birth
certificates the name of their mother
twice not just as their mother but again
as the Commissioner of healthy of New
York so she continues to make things
difficult by going on and becoming the
Commissioner of the Food and Drug
Administration she has I think even now
continued to see bio defense fire
security as important part of her
concerns as commissioner but of course
he has a lot of other things to worry
about now as well so the FDA just to
remind you even if it only has a budget
of a couple of billion dollars has to
regulate about a trillion dollars worth
of consumer goods it's estimated that 25
cents out of every dollar of consumer
spending involves a product or a service
that's regulated by the Food and Drug
Administration so really I just can't
imagine anybody better prepare to talk
to us about the problem of pandemic
threats and more generally the history
and future of public health in this
country and in the world so thank you
again for Peggy Hamburg for coming and
I'm really looking forward to hearing
more thank you well thank you very much
a very generous and complete
introduction and it is true that my
children are the only children in the
history of New York City that have their
birth certificate signed twice and I
actually turned down a job in Washington
so that I could ensure that they both
had that opportunity but it really is a
pleasure to be here and to kick off what
I guess is a lecture series that will go
the course of the summer in conjunction
with a summer school class that you're
all enrolled in and it looks like it's
going to be a busy fascinating summer
and quite a outstanding group of
speakers who will be following at this
podium after me you know I I have to
confess that I don't talk to all that
many groups of students these days
the circuit I'm on is a little bit
different but it's always fun and I
suspect that we'll have a livelier
discussion than in some of the settings
where I speak but so in many ways I envy
you know all of you students that have
the chance to sit and learn and listen
and engage and it's a time that I really
do miss I also in some ways don't envy
you because you are the ones that are
going to be inheriting I think some of
the most complex and formidable public
health challenges that we have yet had
to face so I'm grateful to professor's
Connelly and Morse that they are going
to be exposing you to an aggressive
three-month plan to prepare you for all
the things that we're going to be
counting on you to do in the future it
is really a treat to come back to New
York City and to be able to talk about a
subject that is a great interest and
concern to me and that I have long been
interested in from many different
perspectives and New York City is very
special to me and that this is really
where I began my career in public health
and it's been a career that has taken me
in many extraordinary but unexpected
directions I had always actually thought
that I would pursue a career in academic
medicine and it was really you know
quite focused in my belief in that
regard but as I was going through
Medical School and completing my
residency in internal medicine here in
New York I realized that that really it
didn't feel quite right and I decide to
go down to Washington and learn a little
bit about the world of health policy at
the time my chairman of medicine and
your
it'll said to me if you're not back in
two years to do your sub specialty
training and endocrinology which was my
original plan you will have thrown away
your entire medical career but I went
down nonetheless thinking it might just
be a two-year stint and soon after I
went down to Washington I got a job
working with Tony foul Chi at the
national suit of allergy and infectious
diseases and I know he's going to be on
your your schedule later and I know
you're going to find him both
fascinating and very dynamic but that
was an extraordinary job that really
exposed me to the intersection of what
was somewhat familiar research and
clinical medicine with the broader world
of policy and I found myself getting
more and more drawn into the world of
Public Health which really allowed me to
work increasingly at the intersection of
science and medicine and the broader
world of legal economic social and
ethical concerns a few years later in
1991 I was given the opportunity to
become new york city's health
commissioner and was it not a job that
I'd ever had my eye on that's for sure
but I was excited a little scared but I
said yes my great aunt Winnie who sort
of been like a grandmother to me was
completely baffled by the decision
though she said how can you after all
this training give up on being a real
doctor and she really was troubled my
father tried to calm her down a little
bit and say you know just think of it
that instead of having one patient at a
time she's still a real doctor but now
she has eight million and now that I'm
Commissioner of the Food and Drug
Administration I sort of like to think
that I have you know something over 300
million patients and it is a big
responsibility but I really see public
health strategy and action as key to
achieving meaningful and enduring
solutions to the serious problems that
affect the health and well-being of our
and of the world and you know frankly
I've never looked back and I mentioned
all of this just to try to reinforce my
excitement about the field and hopefully
what you share as you're learning more
in studying public health and hopefully
trying to think about a career in some
aspect of public health the Institute of
Medicine defines the mission of Public
Health as fulfilling society's interest
in assuring conditions in which people
can be healthy which means that the
field of public health is uniquely
positioned to address the complex
interdisciplinary challenges of our
world and to really impact on them in a
substantial and sustainable way this
mission has its roots in the earliest of
civilizations the Romans for one
understood the connection between good
health and proper disposal of human
waste the Chinese developed variolation
to inoculate against smallpox and other
diseases the practice of quarantine was
used in the Middle Ages to contain
infectious disease you probably already
know all of this but it is striking and
since it's a historical perspective for
this series it's worth noting we really
have come a very long way since those
early days and since you know the more
modern pioneers of modern public health
since Jon Snow removed the handle from
the Broad Street pump to stop a cholera
epidemic and established the science of
Epidemiology since Edward Jenner and we
pastor developed the first vaccines for
smallpox and for anthrax and since Sarah
Josephine Baker led a team of doctor of
nurses actually not doctors door to door
down in Manhattan's health kitchen to
educate mothers treat blindness prevent
sexually transmitted diseases trained
midwives and provide pasteurized milk in
the 20th century the dramatic increase
achieved an average lifespan has been
widely attributed to public health
accomplishments thanks to such things as
AXA nation campaigns and sanitation but
also safety programs ranging from
seatbelt use to occupational and
environmental safety to smoke free
programs and nutrition education so
public health is a force to be reckoned
with because it is a way of really
inserting itself into so many aspects of
our lives and their major rewards both
personal and professional was mentioned
that when I was Commissioner here in New
York City back in the 90s I saw the
damage of drug-resistant tuberculosis
and what it could do to a city's
population but I also had the
extraordinary opportunity to really make
a difference back in 91 when I took the
job New York City was reporting the
highest TV case rate that it had had in
almost three decades and as was also
mentioned in many ways a lot of people
didn't really care they saw it as a
disease of historical interest even
though as you looked at the numbers they
were growing in some communities in New
York City were really significantly
devastated by this disease and it posed
a threat for us all you probably all
know that TB is an intrinsically
treatable and controllable disease yet
it had reached epidemic proportions and
with startling lee high levels of
drug-resistant strains that were much
more difficult to treat and to cure
effectively and it really took very
little in many ways to make a difference
but it did take a well-designed TV
control and prevention program adequate
resources but remember it was costing
the city a lot as well to let it go and
to let it continue to grow but it also
took real political and programmatic
commitment from the mayor and from
others in leadership but it was
extraordinary in only a few years we
were able to actually reduce the
percentage of the number of
drug-resistant
TB cases by about eighty six percent so
that was that was really something I had
never dreamed of in fact people had told
me when I embarked on on this effort
that if we didn't address all of the
underlying social issues and just tried
to treat TB we would make no difference
so I think we demonstrated that while we
cared about those underlying social
issues as well we designed a program
that recognized how those issues housing
and addiction and concomitant disease
and of course the hiv/aids epidemic
impacted TB but we were able to design a
program that actually made a difference
and brought the numbers down and at the
end of the day it really was about the
principles and practices of Public
Health and it really i think underscored
for me what my first boss when I went
down to Washington to learn about health
policy had told me of Surgeon General
dr. everett Koop who in many ways
remains a legend but he once said health
care is vital to all of us some of the
time but public health is vital to all
of us all of the time so you know since
this is a bit of a historical
perspective you know it's it's well
worth thinking about all of the
victories that public health has had in
our own little way in New York City but
the eradication of smallpox the control
of polio the dozens of successful
campaigns against deadly diseases and
while it's not actually strictly in the
the public health domain it's kind of
agriculture but they were late I read
today that that we've declared
rinderpest eradicated which is a disease
of animal populations but we still have
a very long way to go we all recognize
that in the developing world there's
been a growing focus on the need for
improved public health and the
tremendous burden that infectious
diseases malnutrition and poverty
related illnesses take killing millions
every year
and of course causing extraordinary
preventable disease and disability and
in our own country we still are at risk
from both infectious diseases and of
course increasingly chronic disease
threats like diabetes heart disease and
hypertension that many have now labeled
as being true epidemics but it's not as
though the developing world is immune
from these chronic disease threats as
well I was of the generation that
learned in medical school that the era
of infectious diseases was over I don't
think that's quite true but I think what
we have to recognize is that that in
some parts of the world the year of
chronic disease is really taking off and
this is not a session to talk about that
but the issues of the growing epidemics
of chronic disease in the developing
world and the developed world would
certainly be another interesting agenda
forth for this this this class but you
know I think that that today we really
are going to focus on pandemic disease
emerging disease threats which really do
represent a continuing area of risk and
vulnerability in this country and around
this world and of course as we live in
an increasingly complex global world a
disease in one person's backyard halfway
around the globe can be in our backyard
within a day and we need to think and
act in a global way and we also have to
sadly recognize that the opportunities
for deliberate manipulation of
biological agents to do harm in the form
of biological terrorism biological
weapons is a reality in the world we
live in and we really need to think
about the kinds of comprehensive
responses that we require to be prepared
as a nation and as an international
community and that that collaboration of
course must involve government academia
industry
international organizations and of
course the not-for-profit world and FDA
the Food and Drug Administration does
have a particularly crucial role to play
and I think it might be helpful before
going any further for me to give you
just a little bit of a background on the
FDA it's not an agency that I think
everybody knows much about although i
think recognition of the the words FDA
or the acronym FDA does in polling get a
pretty high recognition and for the most
part the response to FDA is pretty
positive in terms of trust and
confidence in government agencies but
there was one survey that I saw shortly
after I took this job that ranked us
just above the IRS and so I thought wow
I guess I can only do better but the FDA
was created back in 1906 when President
Teddy Roosevelt signed the pure food and
drug act in response to really a growing
number of dangerous patent medicines
that were on the market and also Upton
Sinclair's now famous expose of the
meatpacking industry there was
considerable public outrage and in
response Teddy Roosevelt signed the pure
food and drug act into law vowing to
protect the public against misbranded or
poisonous or deleterious foods drugs
medicines and liquors and then
interestingly a few decades later
another President Roosevelt this time
FDR signed the Food Drug and Cosmetic
Act which really created the modern FDA
and today the FDA really represents a
very unique resource for our nation it's
a regulatory agency that takes
science-based data-driven action on
behalf of the American people and our
mission is to promote and protect the
health of the public
and of course we take our mission very
seriously the FDA is responsible for
ensuring the safety and efficacy and
security of drugs medical devices
vaccines and biological products as well
as the safety of our nation's food
supply cosmetics dietary supplements
animal drugs and feed certain products
that emit radiation and most recently
tobacco products shortly after i became
commissioner there was a new piece of
legislation that for the first time ever
gave the fda the authority to regulate
tobacco product and their advertising
and as was mentioned these products make
up somewhere between 20 and 25 percent
of consumer product spending in the
United States and I think it's fair to
say with the notable exception of
tobacco the products we regulate our
products that really matter to health
and quality of life and products that
people really care about and rely on in
some fundamental often life-saving ways
and you know I think without a doubt we
have an extraordinary range and a unique
set of responsibilities all aspects of
our mission are really crucial to the
health of individuals and to the public
health of our nation and increasingly
two nations all over the world and I
think that that this all argues for the
fact that we really need to be
recognized as an agency that fulfills
this unique place in our in our world in
our personal wives and the health of our
nation and that if we don't do our job
and do it well there really is no other
entity no other agency of government no
other private sector entity or
not-for-profit sector or aspect of the
academic world that can really step in
and do it for us and I think it's
important to underscore this at a time
when when many are questioning
the appropriate role of government and
certainly many are questioning the role
of regulation with respect to the focus
of this particular lecture series the
history and future of pandemics and
global health obviously I want to talk
some about the FDA role in our role in
preventing and containing disease
outbreaks and infectious disease threats
all over the world is really quite
multifaceted we approve Diagnostics
drugs and vaccines that come before us
but we also act proactively our
scientists and policy experts have
forged partnerships that have led to the
development of novel products to prevent
and treat outbreaks and in times of
crisis we work on the front lines to do
whatever it takes to protect those at
risk in fact we have a long tradition of
leadership and disease prevention and
control efforts even though it probably
is not the first thing that people think
about when they're considering the
charge of our agency and so I hope but
this evening to give you a little bit of
a historical glimpse into the
intersection between FDA and infectious
disease prevention and control both here
in the United States and around the
world and when I'm done hopefully to be
able to talk about a whole set of other
issues that may be of interest to you
that are under the jurisdiction of FDA
but that I haven't had time to touch on
so let me begin sort of near the
beginning and try to frame some of our
issues at FDA in a broad historical
context with a few concrete examples and
I think it's striking to note that like
much in public health the expansion of
our activities and the provision of
important new authorities and rolls for
the FDA has occurred in the context of
responding to a crisis I mentioned that
our very origins were in response to
public concerns over adulterants and
contamination of food and drugs I'll
mention a couple of other sort of
critical events that relay
to infectious disease threats and
disease outbreaks that have also been
critical in the history of FDA in the
1920s an entire family died after eating
canned olives that had been contaminated
with deadly botulism spores this was
naturally occurring of course but the
tragedy drew a lot of attention the FDA
then worked closely with the canning
industry to change manufacturing methods
and procedures in an attempt to
eliminate the anaerobic bacteria from
canned foods using innovations at least
at the time they seemed like innovations
in manufacturing such things as higher
temperatures and longer processing time
then in 1938 the Food Drug and Cosmetic
Act granted FDA direct authority to
conduct factory inspections and finally
after 1972 incident involving more
deaths from botulism this time in canned
soup FDA enacted its first good
manufacturing practice regulations to
govern low acid canned foods and that
includes things like olives but also
green bean soups and other things and
those practices are in place today but
it's sort of amazing to me at least when
I look at history how long it took to
put in place some things that you know
seem pretty basic and straightforward
and how at certain junctures in this
activity it was really considered you
know really quite extraordinary that
that an agency like the FDA would be
stepping in to tell industry how to do
its business and then to create
regulations to oversee something like
good manufacturing practice in another
example in September 1943 the middle of
the Second World War the federal
government's wartime research agency
asked the FDA to assume responsibility
for testing each production lot of
penicillin prior to its application in
the war effort and of course penicillin
which was you know fairly new was
increasingly a critical medicine in the
treatment of infectious disease in the
battlefield
and at that time us manufacturers were
struggling to produce adequate amounts
of this new wonder drug in fact the u.s.
in collaboration with Great Britain
maintained parallel programs to produce
penicillin naturally via fermentation
and three synthetic means as well to try
to make sure that they're there could be
a supply as industry was trying to
figure out how to do this business the
fda tested samples from each lot for
potency toxicity sterility and other
factors and if the samples met the
standards that were agreed upon by the
army navy and fda it could be released
for use in the war effort and then a
much smaller portion was also used for
research purposes and also a small
amount was kept for application in the
civilian community two years later
Congress passed the penicillin amendment
which vested in the FDA the authority
for certifying the drug which by that
time had become considerably easier to
produce then looking forward about 40
years to a time that some of you in the
room may remember but not all I want to
say something about the FDA's role in
the AIDS epidemic and over this 40-year
period the FDA's role in the oversight
of drugs and their manufacturer as well
as their evaluation for safety and
efficacy had changed quite dramatically
but in the early days of the AIDS
epidemic we really had no available
treatments and those circumstances
really led to some new and important
ways of thinking which have had
important continuing effects I was in
medical school back when the AIDS
epidemic emerged and I remember you know
very clearly after having been taught
that the year of infectious diseases was
basically over watching this this
strange unknown disease emerged mainly
affecting young previously healthy
individuals nobody knew what the cause
was nobody knew what to call it I
remember
grid gay-related immune deficiency
syndrome was 14 h syndrome with another
because the main populations affected
were those using heroin hemophiliacs
Haitians and homosexuals but then by the
time I did my residency in New York City
the virus that causes the disease have
been discovered the human
immunodeficiency virus and the disease
condition had gotten its formal official
name AIDS or acquired immune deficiency
syndrome and I was by then taking care
of a lot of AIDS patients but there was
really nothing that we could give them
patients were literally wasting away
before our eyes but there were no drugs
available and we could only really offer
supportive care but in in in many ways
the world changed dramatically thanks to
advances in research and the AIDS crisis
which began with a lot of you know very
vocal concerns about a lack of attention
to the people who were suffering and
their needs really became almost a
poster child for rapid drug development
regulators and drug makers realized that
responding to the epidemic would really
require rewriting the rules and that
delays and the approvals of drugs had
immediate impacts for patients because
they truly had no other options the
focus of individuals was increased by a
loud advocacy community protests by
angry young patients and advocates who
carried tombstones to the front of the
FDA headquarters and some handcuff
themselves to the fence and a few other
things you know did get attention but
but in in truth it was an extraordinary
coming together of the advocacy
community government and scientists to
work together in common cause
with with industry leaders to really
identify a pathway for the scientific
study of the disease itself and
pathogenesis and human immune response
and where were the opportunities for
targeted treatment and how could we
develop and approve new drugs in a way
that was timely but also supported the
important needs of safety and efficacy
and it really was quite an extraordinary
time I was at NIH not at FDA and I have
to say that FDA got a lot more heat than
we got at NIH but it really it really
made a difference and it in success in
rapidly approving treatments for AIDS we
only supported a transformative culture
change at FDA which recognized that
finding ways to achieve faster new drug
approvals really was essential to
protecting and promoting the health of
the public and that especially in the
case of serious life-threatening
diseases and infectious disease
outbreaks new ways new strategies had to
be developed and the so-called
fast-track approval was put in place
then and it remains an important means
of making life-saving therapies
available in a timely manner it's really
crucial when we think about strategies
to help make new promising therapies
available in the setting of diseases
were there very very few options for
care and it is an essential component of
Public Health preparedness as well and
though many think of FDA as a clunky
bureaucratic agency in fact we do know
how to mobilize to respond to an
emergency or a serious emerging public
health concern whether a foodborne
outbreak or an unanticipated pandemic
early last year for instance the
emergence of the novel h1n1 influenza
virus posed a very real threat to the
health of millions of Americans
people around the world and in the in
the context of this emerging evolving
threat FDA scientists investigators and
other professionals had to mobilize
quickly collaborate widely and think
creatively to deliver medications
personal protective equipment
diagnostics and vaccines that that could
help us with rapid identification of the
emerging threat and also in in reducing
illness saving lives and hopefully
preventing disease one key element was
FDA's approval of multiple safe and
effective vaccines against the novel
h1n1 strain which was done in record
time although not quite as quickly as we
had all hoped largely due to the
intrinsic characteristics of the virus
in terms of growth the manufacturers
produced the vaccine and FDA licensed
factories and the decision was much
discussed about what type of vaccine to
develop and how it should be done but
ultimately the determination was made
that we should use the same process the
same steps that were used every year to
develop seasonal flu vaccines because it
was a tried-and-true method so the
process was begun FDA played a role in
creating the seed virus for the vaccine
and then of course we had a critical
role in terms of monitoring the
production process inspecting the
vaccine lots for safety purity and
potency and we collaborated with the CDC
and other agencies to monitor for
unexpected or severe adverse events but
ultimately tens of millions of Americans
were were protected by a vaccine that
proved as expected to have an excellent
safety profile and you know we were
fortunate that in fact the h1n1 virus
wasn't as
as lethal as some originally feared so
in fact it was not of a magnitude that
that we had all initially worried about
and as public health professionals we
prepared for the worst-case scenario but
we were delighted that it wasn't such a
serious threat but our involvement with
the response to h1n1 involve some
aspects that that probably were less
appreciated but had public health
importance as the public health fears
about h1n1 escalated there were all
kinds of crazy products that started to
be marketed shampoos herbal teas air
purifiers electronic equipment that you
could charge yourself with and dozens of
other fraudulent products including
counterfeit Tamiflu so our agency
actually has the responsibility for
monitoring and responding to these kinds
of product concerns and we took swift
enforcement action to shut down these
operations it was a little bit like
playing whack-a-mole they were many many
sites close to it I think there were
about 80 different websites that we
ultimately shut down but you would shut
down one and it would open up somewhere
else but happily most manufacturers did
seem to to respond quickly to our
warnings and we were able to to I think
reduce the potential exposure of people
to products that might actually have
harmed them and to products that might
have prevented them from taking other
actions including treatment that might
have actually had benefits and we also
had a important role in making certain
treatments that were not yet
fda-approved available in an emergency
situation
where it looked like there might be real
benefit to their use one example was in
changing formulations for pediatric
populations so that that kids who didn't
fit within the official indication for
use of antivirals could potentially
benefit from them or making an
intravenous form of an antiviral agent
parameter available for seriously ill
patients in intensive care units and
requiring intravenous therapy and since
the time of we also were able to get a
new set of Diagnostics available for use
in a timely way all under something
called the emergency youth use
authorization Authority which enables us
with an appropriate database and
assessment of risks and benefits to make
these products available in an emergency
and then since that time we've been
working with many of the companies that
that produce these products to actually
get them approved new diagnostic tools
which are so important medications and
of course we are continuing to work with
the scientific community and with
industry to try to develop a better more
modern vaccine against influenza so that
we don't have to be dependent really on
what is now and outmoded and and
cumbersome technology and as we we do
these things we're of course always
thinking about being prepared for the
next challenge whatever it may be just
one other example I haven't been
watching the time give me the hook when
needs be in terms of some of our work
that has global implications last summer
some of you may know a meningococcal a
conjugate
scene was developed through the
meningitis vaccine project and it was
pre qualified by the World Health
Organization to ensure that it met
international standards of quality
safety and efficacy and we worked with
the World Health Organization in that
process since the vaccine which was
manufactured by the serum Institute of
India was introduced now vaccination
campaigns have been held in Burkina Faso
Molly and Anna share and nearly 20
million people were actually vaccinated
in six months which is extraordinary in
and of itself and according to the wh 0
the vaccine is expected to eliminate the
primary cause of epidemic meningitis in
Africa if introduced in all 25 countries
what has come to be known as the
meningitis belt and will save as many as
150,000 lives by 2015 so it's a very
important contribution but there is a
back story that I want to tell you about
FDA scientists specifically those in our
Center for biologics Evaluation and
Research were instrumental in
facilitating the development of this
vaccine not just working with wh 0 in
the pre-qualification process they were
able to develop a method called
conjugation technology that can increase
the immunogenicity and duration of
protection afforded by a vaccine we then
established a cooperative research and
development agreement with the serum
Institute of India and Sieber scientists
transferred the technology to the Indian
scientists and provided them with
technical support as they scaled up to
produce the vaccine for millions of
people so for me that's a wonderful
example of our our proactive role as a
regulatory authority but also as a
scientific public health agency and I
think it reflects that in every realm of
our work importantly including in the
realm of infectious diseases we take
both parts of our mission to promote and
protect the public health very seriously
clearly we always need to be prepared
for the next threat whether the
emergence of an old familiar foe or the
own or unexpected in fact as health
commissioner here in New York City it
was what I really came to appreciate the
importance of the study and practice of
responding to emerging infectious
disease threats and came to know the
work of Stephen Morse and his
extraordinary leadership in this area
but as health commissioner I really saw
that New York City was an important hub
for issues that truly represented global
health concerns and that often were on
the cutting edge of emerging infectious
disease threats whether things like
hiv/aids or the resurgence of
tuberculosis to unexpected diseases like
West Nile and of course to bioterrorism
which came in the form of letters
containing deadly anthrax powder which
brings me to the future part of the the
lecture series and looking ahead to how
the FDA must act to protect the public
from emerging disease threats for years
to come and this is a very serious task
after all both deliberate and naturally
occurring threats specifically threats
that may come through mother nature but
threats that that may be beyond simply
infectious disease but reflect the
threat of terrorism certainly infectious
disease biological terrorism but also
chemical radiologic and nuclear threats
we have to recognize just how important
this area of work is and how it it
really must integrate with all of the
work we do more broadly to protect and
promote the health of the public but but
certainly these kinds of emerging
threats are a special case in that they
lead to social political and economic
disruption in ways that go beyond the
norm and they
have the potential to take a truly
catastrophic toll on life and health and
of course in our increasingly
interconnected global community we the
United States not the only country
affected and we need to think about the
ways in which both our nation and the
world remain vulnerable and there has
been significant progress in thinking
about the development of public health
preparedness against naturally occurring
in deliberate threats but we still have
a significant ways to go from the FDA
perspective one area of major concern is
that we lack the medical countermeasures
that we need to combat both the known
threats as well as the capacity to
rapidly develop new ones in the face of
emerging threats and that really is not
acceptable if we're to truly protect the
public's health we need to develop the
medical tools to ensure rapid diagnosis
treatment and prevention in case of a
real attack or a potential threat and in
the bigger picture medical
countermeasures really can contribute
significantly to the deterrence of
biological weapons development in use
and should deterrence fail help minimize
their consequences the good news is that
that we are poised to make some
important and exciting changes and I'm
very pleased and proud really of the
growing role that my agency the FDA has
played and continue to play in
implementing them as part of a new
medical countermeasures initiative that
was announced last August we at FDA are
working hard to increase access to an
availability of safe effective medical
countermeasures which is an
administration-wide priority in
something that both the president and
the Secretary of Health and Human
Services have talked about and take very
seriously and that FDA we're doing this
in three major ways by supporting the
development of an
review and manufacturing approaches for
the highest priority countermeasures by
examining the legal policy and
regulatory framework and by
strengthening the science that we need
to more efficiently develop medical
countermeasures and to facilitate the
evaluation of product safety efficacy
quality and performance and this last
effort in particular will allow FDA to
identify and help solve the scientific
challenges that hinder medical
countermeasure development and problems
that without solutions will continue to
result in long delays in the face of a
crisis and getting the products that we
need and that is something that must be
a high priority but it's it's really a
huge scientific challenge imagine how
hard it is both to develop and to assess
for safety and efficacy a drug or a
vaccine or even a diagnostic when in
fact the disease doesn't exist in nature
or exists in very small quantities or
when it exists is sufficiently serious
and or lethal that to introduce studies
in humans could put people considerably
at risk also the challenge of trying to
develop platforms mechanisms of vaccine
development for example that reflect
understanding of the underlying disease
process and the human immune response
but that are being developed to put in
place when something completely unknown
emerges but will give us a significant
leg up in terms of a rapid response to
develop a vaccine that might make a
difference so what is clear to me is
that we need to work in these difficult
challenging scientific areas but that we
really cannot do it alone the scientific
community must come together government
industry
and academia to ensure that we have the
knowledge and tools to enable us to cope
with the challenges of the future and to
address the scientific uncertainty that
we face and in addition we must learn to
work in a coordinated and truly
cooperative way with all the many
partners and stakeholders necessary for
effective preparedness and response in
one of the things that I've certainly
learned over the past two years and this
job is that you know the ability to
accomplish so much of what is core to
our mission and certainly the things
that I've been talking about today
really requires creative partnerships
and a commitment to truly
interdisciplinary ideas it involves a
willingness to always a question the way
we do things and understand whether
there are our better ways to get to our
important goals and certainly I worry
all the time about who's going to be
doing these kinds of jobs and taking on
these kinds of activities in the future
which is why talking to students and be
engaged in a lecture series like this is
so important I really do think that the
the world is changing and the challenges
in terms of emerging disease threats and
global health are both more daunting
than ever before but also more exciting
than ever before and the opportunity to
really bring the best possible science
to bear to understand public health
practices and what works and what
doesn't and to bring together
perspectives that Mary science medicine
and public health with with development
both economic and human development and
with with issues of security both
security in the sense of food security
for example and making sure that people
have access to what they need but
security in the sense of protection
against threats on both the national
and international level it all comes
together in my view in public health we
have a unique opportunity to really
seize the moment I hope that that in
these you know more formal remarks I've
been able to say a few things that are
of interest to you and that we can have
some discussion in other key areas but
most of all I hope that through through
this talk but but importantly the whole
series that you'll be getting over the
course of the summer you will really
leave with the sense of enthusiasm and
hopefully commitment to public health as
a career because it is extraordinary and
I only wish that I had discovered it a
bit earlier in my career so thank you
very much and let's do some some
questions
thank you so much we can call your
Commissioner Hamburg again so for as
always I think a lucid and fascinating
presentation there's a microphone for
those who want to ask questions and you
can ask them your professor well so
thanks for coming to speak to us
commissioner I was wondering if maybe
you could turn a bit to your time at the
nuclear threat initiative and in the
past you've talked about the dangers of
dual-use research of research either for
defense against bio weapons or for
medical research that can both be turned
into research for offensive capabilities
and i was wondering number one if you
think the kind of frameworks that we
have internationally have been adequate
whether they were doomed from the start
things like the biological weapons
convention to deal with those threats
which seemed to worsen with new
technology and number two now given your
time at the FDA what really keeps you up
at night is it a doomsday terrorist
scenario that seems to you know make a
lot of the plot lines of shows like 24
or is it something more like the 1982
tylenol incident or lead in children
toys okay um well as respect to the
first part of your question you know I I
you know early on you know did raise
questions about the need for awareness
that as we advanced our knowledge and
understanding of biomedical research and
life sciences research and related
emerging technologies we needed to
recognize that there were potential miss
applications of this research I think
it's a continuing concern and it's it's
not unique to the area of life sciences
I think you know almost every new
technology that's been developed has had
some miss application as well but I
think it is it was it was very important
to begin to engage in the discussions
so that people doing the research you
know recognized the complexity of some
of the new capabilities and that we try
to develop you know some ways of
thinking about it both in terms of
training of young scientists and also in
terms of frameworks for governance and
oversight in some ways I'm not as close
to that arena of activity as I as I once
was but my sense is that while initially
there was a lot of understandable
resistance in the many parts of the
research community that you know well
we're the white hats we're doing this
research in order to try to find new
treatments and cures you know how how
can it be that you know you'd be asking
questions about misapplication I think
there has been a recognition that
especially moving into areas that have
enormous power including synthetic
biology and advances in genomics and
other areas that we do need to be
mindful it doesn't mean that the
research should stop but it does mean
that that we need just as in other
aspects of scientific research we strive
to to balance both the scientific
research needs with the ethical context
in which it's done with respect to the
biological weapons convention I think
you know it's it's been certainly a less
effective vehicle on a global scale than
many had hoped initially I think that
there are many good elements in terms of
the approach that has been taken in some
of the specific areas that have been
developed as sort of components of how
to strengthen the understanding of the
fundamental issues involved but I'm
really not close enough to it
to comment on on the state of the
biological weapons convention you asked
another question that was a good Oh what
keeps me up at night you know and I do
have many things to worry about and
every day there's something new to worry
about it seems like but I would say that
the the issue of greatest concern to me
really is one that I thought about
talking about in more detail today so
you give me an opportunity and that's
the issue of globalization and import
safety and the security of the global
supply chain whether you look at food or
you look at at drugs and medical
products it's extraordinary how in just
the last few decades the number of
products that FDA regulates come either
in whole or in part from other parts of
the world in the food arena it's about
forty percent of fresh fruit and produce
and close to eighty percent of seafood
as examples come from countries outside
of our borders and with respect to drugs
about forty percent of the drugs we take
here or actually produced in total
somewhere else for aspirin it's
seventy-five or eighty percent of all
aspirin taken here comes from somewhere
else and about eighty percent of the
active pharmaceutical ingredients and
drugs used here actually come from other
countries with India and China being
among the largest sources but it's quite
a wide array for an agency whose initial
authorities and focus really was were
developed in an era when you
realistically could monitor the boats
coming into port and roll a few kegs of
molasses off and inspect them and then
send them along the world looks really
very different and we're now responsible
for tens of millions of lines of
products that come in to a very large
number of ports both seaports and river
ports and
and through airports and border sites
coming from you know probably a 180 or
so different countries and and certainly
be products that are produced in
hundreds of thousands of facilities
around the world with very complex
supply chains that may involve like on
the food side a grower but then between
that farm somewhere in the world's and
your fork there are manufacturers
processors packagers repackage errs
distributors exporters importers so the
supply chain is very complex and there
are many points along the way for the
introduction deliberately or
unintentionally of contamination or
adulteration and it's a very very
serious concern and we we live it every
day you know small foodborne outbreaks
or large foodborne outbreaks you know
are in the news all the time and for
those of you that follow promed can keep
up with breaking news as steve just
commented on something that I thought I
was privy to but he didn't but no one
else would know but but on the the drug
side we certainly know that the the
threats are real in terms of both
counterfeit drugs and the deliberate
economic adulteration of products like
heparin a blood-thinning drug that was
contaminated and appeared to be
associated with significant illness and
some death or the ethylene glycol and
cough syrup that didn't affect us in
this country but but killed many
children in other parts of the world or
ethylene glycol and in toothpaste that
was in this country
elsewhere so with there are very real
concerns and it's it's it's a huge
challenge for us to really monitor the
safety of the supply chain and provide
the oversight that we want to to ensure
the safety and quality integrity of
these products and really the only way
that we will be successful and the the
path that I am very much embarked on is
to develop a new paradigm which which
relies on partnership partnership with
our sister regulatory authorities
partnership with other key stakeholders
including industry who at the end of the
day shares a common goal with us of not
having contaminated products that can
undermine trust and confidence and their
brand and finding new ways to to
introduce preventive strategies so that
we're not scrambling after problems once
they occur but the tried and true public
health method of prevention to try to
identify where are the greatest points
of vulnerability and how can we Shore
them up and a big part of that is
something that that I'm very committed
to and just came back from a meeting of
the APEC economies the Asian Pacific
economies where we signed a memorandum
of understanding of the World Bank to
really try to strengthen regulatory
capabilities in the food safety arena in
the developing world both to address
this issue of raising the quality and
standards that foods are grown and
produced under regardless of where in
the world that's happening but also
because strengthening the regulatory
capacity provides countries especially
those with developing economies a very
important opportunity both to be able to
ensure high quality and more and a more
reliable food source within their own
nation but also to be
able to support a key sector of their
economy potentially and build up export
opportunity that can help their economic
as well as human development so that is
you know really something of great
interest to me and I think a huge issue
for our country and other nations going
forward thank you for coming you stated
in your lecture tonight that sufficient
public health preparedness may deter
biological weapons use could you talk
more about this concept of deterrence
why do you believe that public health
preparedness may deter people and who or
what needs to be deterred okay um well I
think you know this is you know really
focused on the issue of deliberate
attacks using biological agents and we
know that you know many countries around
the world including our own nation at
one point you know have been interested
and have worked on biological weapons
programs and it's a very unique
asymmetrical threat potentially that you
don't need especially in the modern era
Science and Technology a nation state to
develop biological weapons potentially
and so it can become an attractive tool
of terrorism as well but it's really
only attractive as a weapon of terrorism
if it can produce panic and terror and
disruption of government and lack of
confidence of the public in government
and critical institutions and take a
huge toll on both life and the economic
health of an area as well and so if
we're unprepared it is guaranteed that
all of those negative consequences can
and
will unfold in response to a large or
even a small attack but if we are
prepared and we can mobilize quickly or
if we have the tools to put in place a
prevention strategy before something
ever happens then the use of a
biological weapon as a the terrorist
agent is going to be a lot less
attractive and that's what I meant by
deterrence and I think you know in the
real world we have to take this threat
very seriously we know it has happened
has happened over the course of history
and it's happened in our lifetimes in
this country many of the doomsday
scenarios that that people have talked
about and I've certainly played in a lot
of exercises that were truly
catastrophic using biological agents
those kinds of scenarios have a nun
folder hopefully they never will and I
think that as a nation will be a mistake
to completely organized our investments
in public health and other investments
toward addressing those kinds of
potentially catastrophic threats but I
think it's very important for us to
recognize that they are part of the
continuum of serious infectious disease
threats that we face both naturally
occurring and deliberately caused and
that we need to make sure that we have
the various components of a
comprehensive public health preparedness
program in place that involves much more
than some of the things I was talking
about in terms of the FDA role which is
more really focused on on a range of
medical countermeasures and helping to
build up some of the the scientific
capabilities and the innovative products
that are necessary to to prepare and
respond but i think it's vitally
important but at the same time that that
these capacities are being built and the
last decade is seeing you know some
significant investments i think we want
to be investing in things that will help
to protect us against naturally occur
disease threats because I think that we
know that mother nature can be a very
powerful terrorist in her own right and
that for a lot of reasons we will
continue to be vulnerable to a set of
known and unknown infectious disease
threats one of the big battles during
hiv/aids crisis has been the pricing of
the cocktail to cure it and who controls
that and as you know there's a big with
a big fight about multinational
pharmaceuticals versus the production of
generic solutions to it let's say in
India and I was wondering where we're at
on this issue what do we learn from
these experiences and where we at in
terms of the policy of the government to
handle these kind of troubling and
vexing questions yeah well a complicated
set of issues and ones where there are
you know good examples and they're bad
examples in terms of industry practice
and pricing the FDA makes its decisions
about products that come before us on
the basis of demonstration of safety and
efficacy and and pricing is not you know
criteria but in terms of the overall
access to critical drugs therapeutics
vaccines and other medical products we
all know that the price is a huge
barrier to appropriate use and
especially in countries and often in
populations that are most at risk with
the greatest problems with getting the
medicating access to the medicines that
the people people need generic drugs
obviously has been a huge contribution
to making important drugs more available
and in this country the shift from
innovator brand drugs to generics has
been quite extraordinary I think about
eighty percent of the prescriptions
written in this country
they are for generic drugs and that has
you know really brought down costs of
drugs and of course as part of the
response to hiv/aids there was a major
effort to make generic drugs available
in the health world an FDA played a very
significant role in that and we approved
through a mechanism that's called
tentative approval but it's not
tentative it's but over a hundred I
think different different products as
part of that effort to get more drugs to
people who need them with respect to the
hiv/aids epidemic in in the developing
world you know a huge issue now and
going forward is how can we are speaking
really with my FDA had on you know how
can we help support efforts to bring
down the cost of developing new medical
products and and do it in a timely er
way as well because time is money when
it comes to to drug research and
development and and in my mind that
means applying better science to the
process of drug development and review
and also for FDA to take a very serious
look at our regulatory pathways and how
can they be streamlined and modernize
partly through the use of better science
and partly you know looking at business
processes and what can be achieved but
you I'm sure know the numbers although
there's debate about you know the sort
of ballpark of the numbers but it it
costs hundreds of thousands of dollars
to bring a drug to market and can take
you know a decade to do so and so I
think in terms of looking at the world
scene and unmet public health need we
need to find a better way
thank you so much for speaking with us
today you very briefly mentioned chronic
disease like diabetes and hypertension
so I was wondering if you could speak a
little bit more about that my question
is threefold first what is the FDA doing
to prepare for a chronic disease
epidemic and second what are the
military or state security implications
of chronic disease on military
preparedness and thirdly what are the
public safety implications in your
opinion of being relatively dependent on
a pure supply of metformin and insulin
well let's see if I can remember all
your questions what we're doing with
respect to chronic disease is obviously
trying to help create a regulatory
environment that enables new important
drugs to be developed and brought to
market to treat problems that are huge
and growing diabetes obesity heart
disease etc as well as neurodegenerative
diseases that are going to take an
increasing toll Alzheimer's Parkinson's
and others with an aging population we
also of course have a very special
responsibility for monitoring medical
products throughout their lifecycle so
not just helping the process of review
and approval but also ensuring safety
pre-approval and post approval and we're
putting more attention and resources
into post-marketing surveillance and
monitoring to enable us to identify
safety concerns as they emerge drugs
that are used for chronic conditions do
present a very different profile than
antibiotics or antivirals for infectious
diseases because we're talking about
drugs that are going to be used often
for
the course of a person's lifetime once
they have to start on those drugs and so
it's not surprising that there may be
safety concerns that emerge not in the
pre-approval process when you're dealing
with a limited number of patients taking
the drugs under very controlled
circumstances then you're moving out to
now you know millions tens of millions
of patients potentially taking the drug
taking the drug at the same time that
they're taking other drugs because many
people that have one chronic condition
have many chronic conditions and also
taking it for a prolonged period of time
so this notion of our responsibility for
the life cycle of a product becomes
increasingly important chronic diseases
present somewhat different challenges
than agents against infectious diseases
also because we're not just trying to
either prevent an infectious disease
like we do with the vaccine or treat an
existing condition but we're also
thinking about ways to slow the
progression of a disease particularly
something you know like Alzheimer's but
certainly you know all chronic diseases
the longer you have them and the more
severe they are you know the worst they
are the more debilitating they are the
more serious complications there are
diabetes being one good example and so
to study a drugs impact on the
progression of a disease is also
something of a challenge because you
have to be able to identify and validate
surrogate markers for the study of
whether the disease's progression rather
than having a clear endpoint of disease
no disease you know which is much easier
to do with an antibiotic so chronic
diseases do create a number of
challenges for the drug review and
approval process and a number of
challenges for the ongoing assessment
of safety you asked about the
implications of chronic disease for for
basically for for the military and for
war fighters and that goes a bit beyond
my my certainly my official capacity is
FDA Commissioner but my expertise in
general but obviously you know we need
to think about the needs of the military
not just in the context of things that
they might be exposed to and we need to
protect them from which is a big part of
the challenge and an arena that we work
with DoD on all the time but there are
chronic disease concerns that need to be
addressed now of course the military
does screen its members and so certain
kinds of chronic conditions would would
disallow you from being actually
recruited into the military but then
there's also the question of are their
exposures environmental exposures in
particular that that could ultimately
cause chronic disease and they're
complex issues that have emerged in that
arena as you probably know such things
as Agent Orange and it's and its
relationship to to chronic syndromes of
disease or you know in the current wars
in Afghanistan and Iraq we are now you
know really dealing with a whole
different set of chronic disease
concerns that are very very significant
and and really so damaging to
individuals and their families both in
terms of the injuries that have have
resulted in loss of limbs from explosive
devices but also post traumatic stress
syndrome and a traumatic brain injury
that leaves these these military
personnel with chronic lasting often
debilitating diseases in many cases
where we have far fewer medical tools
and interventions than
then we would hope for hi first of all
thank you again for coming to meet with
us tonight I think we all really
appreciate it and the second of all
thank you for your work that you do
every day to help with global public
health my question is a bit more of a
historical question i guess the ones
that have been asked already it's about
the regulation of the blood supply by
the fda and i understand that when the
aids pandemic first broke out in the
late 70s that there is a lot of fear
about it and that the blood supply was
regulated in a way that kind of
reflected that fear with a different
community groups and i was wondering if
you could touch a little bit upon how
that decision was made to to make those
referrals and the reanalysis of those
decisions since then and kind of looking
forward what it looks like for blood
donor communities I'm and with a blend
of blood supply okay thank you well you
know protecting the safety the blood
supply is an important component of
FDA's mission and and actually i don't
think i mentioned it when i was talking
about the long list of things that we do
but it's something that's that's very
important and can be quite complex
complex scientifically in terms of what
should we be screening for and do we
actually have the Diagnostics to enable
us to meaningfully screen and how much
risk is acceptable in terms of exposures
through the blood supply and do we have
the framework for monitoring the public
to know what maybe some of the emerging
potential concerns about the safety of
the blood supply and then there's you
know a lot of issues about the
management of the blood supply as well
and we are very involved in shortages of
different kinds of blood components and
and how to address those and how to
monitor to anticipate when there may be
shortages and strategies to try to to
mobilize donors or production of certain
components when shortages start to
emerge so it's very challenging and
important
area with respect to the decision-making
around a particular issue or or
potential component in the blood supply
that that would be screened for there
you know there is a process with careful
analysis of the available data there's
their mechanisms that go beyond you know
just the FDA in terms of the
governmental procedures as well as
advisory committees that help us to sort
out what is known how good are the
screening tests the screening tests both
in terms of identifying at-risk donors
and the screening tests in terms of
actually examining the blood component
so that we can can get rid of it if it's
in fact contaminated and and they're
hard questions and you know certainly
HIV is well demonstrated to transmit
through the blood supply but there are
huge debates about whether individuals
who report to be practicing safe sex and
have no other potential routes of
exposure in terms of intravenous drug
use or whatever whether they should in
fact be allowed to to donate and that is
under discussion now in terms of should
we should we step back from the
stringency of the current donation
standards but it's it's being examined
in a very careful thoughtful way because
there are significant risks involved
with with changing the standards there
are benefits in terms of recruiting more
potential donors and in
you know intertwined with all this is
also the desire not to needlessly
stigmatize a group but their donor
restrictions for many reasons I mean if
you travel in certain countries you're
not allowed to donate if you have had
certain treatments you're not allowed to
donate so there's there is a whole range
of reasons they're all based on the best
available science but always recognizing
that we're weighing you know risks and
benefits and that it's a dynamic process
and we don't lock into one way of doing
it if circumstances change and of course
as new concerns emerge we have to put in
place new screening measures and
strategies as well thank you very much
for coming Commissioner a little while
ago you mentioned barriers to
international partnerships I'm wondering
if you could speak to what you would
consider the biggest barrier to
international partnerships specifically
in the event of a future pandemic um
well you know I think Trust is always a
barrier to partnership and I think past
working relationships or lack thereof
can be a barrier to cooperation I think
a failure to recognize and act with an
appreciation of the perspectives of
different countries has also proven to
be a barrier but i would say that in my
experience in the work that i do through
the FDA
that it's not so much about barriers
it's the eagerness for collaboration
because we all are facing the same
challenges we all feel that we're being
asked to do things that are really
important and really matter but we don't
have the resources or the international
authorities to do all of what needs to
be done when I work with various sister
regulatory authorities there's a huge
sense of desire to find new and better
ways to share information to work
collaboratively to find ways to
harmonize standards and approaches is
something that we talk about a lot but
we're actually moving towards not so
much a focus on harmonizing in the sense
of doing it the same way but achieving
an understanding of each other's
approaches to dealing with certain kinds
of regulatory questions so that we can
have confidence in the outcomes and not
just look at the process because in the
in the realm that I work in sometimes
we've gotten bogged down because we do
things differently but it doesn't
necessarily mean that one is right and
one is wrong if you look at the outcomes
you know one that that I think is kind
of interesting certainly nothing I never
thought about before was that if you're
looking at sea food safety like oysters
you can either test the oyster meat or
you can test the water in which the
oyster is grown and there have been
violent disagreements about what's the
right way to do it but at the end of the
day the question is you know are they
wasters safe to eat and I think you know
so we need to focus on outcomes one of
the things I mentioned is this notion of
you know really strengthening regulatory
capacity and I think that in from the
FDA perspective that is really really
key and I think it has huge
ramifications that go beyond just what
matters for the
da and I'm very excited about that
opportunity and I think that when we can
engage in that kind of activity which is
proactive and constructive and really
makes a difference to the countries that
we're working with then I think there's
a greater willingness to collaborate in
other ways you know for example sharing
of specimens has been an issue sometimes
you know in the context of pandemic flu
certainly the unwillingness of certain
countries indonesia i guess in
particular to share the virus because
you know they you know serve what's in
it for us and it's an understandable
reaction that concerned that that the
virus that might have been found in
their country would go to helping make a
better vaccine for others but what about
of their populations and so I think you
know we also need to think about how can
we both collaborate and share
information and share important
scientific resources but also find
better ways to you know partner in
providing at risk countries communities
and populations the support and help
they need one last question sure thanks
very much for coming today two questions
the first one is when you spoke about
the h1n1 vaccine you said that tens of
millions of Americans had it I'm
wondering why there wasn't hundreds of
millions of Americans that had it and
then the second question which may be
seen as related which may not be seen as
related is I've learning too good to
speak to something you said somewhat
offhandedly at the beginning with
respect to the FDA's was it respect or
kind of recognition just above the IRS's
I are you doing anything to socialize
the FDA within the US and beyond and if
so what if not why not with respect to
the first question
you know vaccination has always been an
area where we have less success than we
we hope for in terms of campaigns and an
uptake although for the routine
preventable illnesses of childhood the
numbers are you know quite good these
days and that's reinforced by certain
requirements like a school districts to
have your children vaccinated but as I'm
sure you're well aware there are sectors
of our population and people around the
world you know that question the value
of vaccines and are concerned about
potential side effects and vaccination
is a medical intervention where we take
in most instances you know healthy
people often healthy children and expose
them to a medical product and no medical
product is completely safe so so there's
always been you know this this issue
about are we achieving vaccination
targets and certainly with h1n1 we had a
higher goal the other problem with the
h1n1 response was that the vaccine came
later than we had hoped and it came
after the peak and it came at a time
when some of the concerns about the
severity of the epidemic had begun to
wane and so people that probably would
have have eagerly taken the vaccine
would have demanded it in fact no longer
wanted it we I think did vaccinate at
higher levels than in the past but still
it was underutilized and we we in fact
we're left with with unused vaccine the
question about FDA and you know our sort
of reputation and the trust and
confidence of the American people i
think is a very very critical one and it
you know really is the linchpin of all
that we do and it's something that I
came in determined to to work on and I
think we have made made progress it's
interesting internationally FDA is
really viewed as the gold standard
within the u.s. there is a something of
a more skeptical public although many
polls still in terms of both name
recognition and support from the public
it still ranks quite high but there was
that survey that i mentioned that that
did get my attention and i think that
you know we are often beaten up by the
media on capitol hill by various
stakeholder groups and by the very
nature of what we do it's hard to make
everyone happy but i think you know the
trust and confidence in our agency in
what we do the the belief that we are a
science-based science-driven agency
confidence in the integrity of our
systems all of that matters enormously
and it you know we initiated soon after
i became commissioner of a major
transparency initiative to try to open
up the fda because we've often been
accused of being a bureaucratic black
box and really in a systematic way tried
to target key stakeholders in terms of
what kind of information they wanted
from us that they felt they weren't
getting trying to make our information
more accessible trying to be more
explicit about what we do and why you
know whether it's putting more
information up and linking to other
websites about foodborne outbreaks
including when the concern is about the
outbreak is actually over because one of
the things we used to do a lot was get
everybody aware
not to eat peanut butter but once the
problem at the factory was resolved
whatever you know we never said okay
it's go it's okay to go back but but so
you know outreach in those kind of ways
and but also you know really trying to
reach target audiences in ways that we
didn't before any of you that read the
New England Journal of Medicine may
notice that the FDA is constantly
publishing articles now about decisions
we've made trying to really lay out the
basis of those decisions and provide
more background on our rationale because
I think it's very very important that
people understand what we do the
complexity of many of the decisions that
we have to make but the fact that it's
not arbitrary and capricious which may
sometimes see if you're just looking
from the outside in and you know to me
you know i feel just very very strongly
that the FDA is an agency that has been
so neglected in many ways over decades
in terms of the investment of resources
to support the the critical set of roles
and responsibilities that we have and
that year after year we are given new
mandates and new responsibilities but we
are not given the resources that we need
correspondingly to really do our job and
I was just looking at the numbers
yesterday in terms of the 2011 budget
and in some ways I can't complain
because over the past couple of years we
have gotten significant budget increases
but I view it that we're still sort of
digging out of a hole and we're still in
that hole but we have gotten increases
but at a time with the 2011 budget which
was just resolved and some of you may
have tracked the government almost shut
down in getting to yes on a budget but
we actually got a very we got a real
increase in our budget when many
agencies including the NIH which usually
is the one that gets the significant
increases got a an actual cut compared
to their 2010 budget we got an increase
but I don't expect to be so lucky for
the 2012 budget which is being debated
now and we're looking at at a very
significant cut on based on what the
house just passed but but I was looking
at the 2011 budget in terms of how much
we get and what it means across the
population of this country and its
dollars that every American pays each
year to support the budget of the FDA
and considering what we do and how much
it matters I really think we need to
take another look and I really feel it's
a very important aspect of what I do to
try to to be an advocate for the
importance of the agency the unique
contribution that we make and the the
need to really pay attention as a nation
because failure to really adequately
support the FDA in our programs will be
at all of our peril oh thank you thank
you so much please join me in thanking
dr. Hamm Gareth wonderful fascinating
and dare I say inspiring presentation
and thank you all for coming and for all
the fascinating questions